inside the jaw-dropping splendor of
Windsor Castle st. George's Chapel is
undergoing preparations for Prince Harry
and Megan Markos nuptials
Charlotte Manley is responsible for the
smooth running of the chapel which
despite its age and grandeur is very
much a family church some George's
Chapel is located within the walls of
Windsor Castle and the castle is thought
of by the Queen as home say it's a very
lovely place to come because it's part
of the castle buildings part of the home
atmosphere almost a domestic feel if you
like the chapel was started in 1475 I
started by one King Edward the fourth
who had it in mind to be his burial
place and he is indeed buried here and
finished roughly fifty years later by
one of the most famous Kings in this
country King Henry the eighth
also buried here as well as burials
it's where Harry was christened at three
months old it's also where the Prince of
Wales and the Duchess of Cornwall held
the blessing for their wedding in 2005
and now it's about to welcome six
hundred wedding guests from the Queen to
Hollywood movie stars and it's a it's a
real joy to welcome people to a very
celebratory occasion
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]